c'est parti il est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça fait un moment qu'on se voit plus
tous les jours j'attends qu'elle me
rappelle je me souviens de nos débuts
[Musique]
j'ai foutu son petit cœur à tête son
corps me manque et je crois bien que ça
sourire aussi et je me demande
j'aimerais savoir ce qu'elle pense aussi
et je peux pas l'oublier je me suis
attaché c'est moi Elvira
beauté j'en ai connu des femmes de toute
elle s'est démarqué elle en a mis des
buts en tout cas moi elle m'a marqué et
je peux pas l'oublier je me suis attaché
c'est Maël virer ma beauté j'en ai connu
des femmes de toutes elles étaient
marquée elle en a mis des en tout
cas moi elle m'a marqué je tourne en
rond je suis trop ma puce je pense à toi
de tes nouvelles ça fait un moment qu'on
se voit plus
faut que tu me rappelles je tourne en
rond je suis dans ma bulle je pense à
toi j'attends tes nouvelles ça fait un
moment qu'on se voit plus il faut qu'on
se voit pour que tu te rappelles
servira
[Musique]
Elvira Elvira Elvira changement
d'ambiance maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laisse-toi aller t'inquiète ça va bien
se passer au lieu de faire la tête viens
avec toi ton fiancer
laisse-toi aller t'inquiète ça va bien
se passer j'ai grandi tout seul en fait
on s'en foutus je veux voir toutes les
mains en l'air ça je sais que tu sais le
faire positionner et puis laisse tomber
je veux voir toutes les mains en l'air
tous ensemble on va le faire
et puis ça vient enlever
tu veux gérer ma peau mon gros mais t'as
pas le gardien
ils sont plusieurs à essayer je crois
bien plus dans votre maître vas-y laisse
température va falloir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'on est jamais fatigué on fait quoi
quoi que ce soit bon on va tout casser
on va pas se coucher je vais voir toutes
les mains en l'air ça je sais si c'est
le faire positionner et puis laisse
tomber je veux voir toutes les mains en
l'air tous ensemble on va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sinon laisse tomber je veux voir toutes
les mains en l'air ça se situe cette
ferme
en l'air tous ensemble
[Musique]
en physique il est en faisant
[Applaudissements]
elle est très très très long c'est
gentil
là c'est quel déjà ma belle ma belle
elle est chaumée
ma belle elle est incroyable c'est ma
première partie juste avant Laurie mais
magique
[Musique]
incroyablement les deux chez d'études
vas-y chante la merde
à chaque fois je te vois ça fait trop
beau
[Musique]
si on fait du mal je ferai pas
rester debout là sur mon chat dedans
quand j'ai vu ma belle j'ai su que je
serai fidèle je suis oublié tes
problèmes beauté féminin je te qui
s'emmène
ma belle ma belle ma belle
quand même elle est incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Lyon il sera à Lille ah non si cartonne
et c'est mérité et les deux sont très
forts c'est gentil bravo mon chéri tu
cartonnes je suis fier de toi je t'aime
fort
[Applaudissements]